hey youtubers is Charlie so a bunch of
you been requesting a video about what's
going on with some of the characters so
this is going to be all about the end of
team flash as you know it there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so we need
to break out the morbius voice again
what if I told you this was the end of
team flash there's always going to be a
speedster on the TV show the team has
been shattered and it's not going to be
put back together in nice tidy pieces
that was the whole idea with the way
that Caitlin ended the series Julianne
constructed the cure for her they could
have turned her right back but there
were some really important reasons for
her character for herself why she didn't
want to take that and there's some
important narrative reasons why the
writers did it that way she sort of had
the lead in for what is going to be
changing for next season and how the
team isn't going to be team flash in the
way that you've known it before so we're
just going around to each of the
storylines and explain like why
everybody is like off doing their own
thing and why team flash has been
completely broken so we all know Barry
is gone the characters have no idea when
he's coming back we as the audience know
how TV works we know that Grant Gustin
is a series regular he's contractually
obligated to appear in pretty much every
episode
so whatever twist you want to think of
force ghost Barry just his voice him
appearing at the end of the episode
he'll be in there somewhere it's just
that the characters like iris have no
idea when he's coming back so they think
he's gone forever but he dubbed Wally
the new flash the city has a flash it's
you carry on in my absence so Wally
takes up the mantle of the flash no
longer calling himself Kid Flash and his
team flash has been shattered
you have the flashpoint team-up
reforming iris and Wally doing the
brother-sister thing that they were
doing before very rolled everything back
so if you really like that idea I feel
like it's much better for irises
character because it gives they're much
more active participation in the plot
like when she's standing around cheering
Barry on that's really good they're good
character moments that she has because
for about half of the season she was the
engine around which all the drama turn
but unless someone's trying to attack
her or she's working on a really big
story that's going to blow some rogue
plot wide open then what is the point
for her to be around
other than being a cheerleader so her
going into detective mode with Wally
them being a team it is way better for
her so if you remember what happened
between season two in season three where
Barry was still trying to help the city
but he was doing out on his own he was
trying to repair everything from the
damage as a particle accelerator
[Music]
Walli will pick up in Barry's absence
but he'll still need help so iris will
step in to fill the gap there's still
people around so it's not like Cisco is
going to completely bail but it's not
like everybody's going to be super happy
and it'll be the exact same as it was
before only with a different flash it's
like when Barry rolled flashpoint back
it's like oh you know all the things
that I changed have been rolled back so
that means that everybody's
personalities should change back to what
they used to be and they were like nope
hard pass Cisco's brother was dead he
was all pissed off at Barry so that gets
back to the idea of killer frost not
taking the cure
so this is the writer saying that we're
not going to completely invalidate
everything that these characters went
through by making them forget
conveniently forget all the bad things
that happen so you start to see this in
the other storylines as we go through
this Traci brand is probably the best
example of this she has her coffee
machine that she still has a
relationship with now the HR isn't
around anymore so she still has her evil
speedster lattes but even though I
expect her to come back to STAR Labs
she's still trying to find meaning
because he was the person that gave her
meaning the person that drove her
otherwise she'd be working at big belly
burger going big belly burger I hear
they're hiring what they're serious well
what about all your research he was the
one that convinced her to stay so just
like Cisco had to get over the death of
his brother it took a little while for
that to happen she'll have to do the
same thing with HR she really wanted
saboteur to die I really liked that
scene where they tried to get her to
help try and save him until they found
out that avatar was leading them on the
whole time she's probably even more mad
about that but moving on to Cisco and
Julianne so as far as we know tom felton
still around they've made no mention of
whether or not he's left the series
whether he's staying on but all signs
are pointing to him coming back they're
mostly obsessed with getting Caitlin
back who wants nothing to do with that
so even though Cisco is still helping
out he's got his relationship with
so he's very preoccupied with that
Gillian is still employed as a Central
City CSI so he's probably stuck himself
in his work he's still a metahuman
expert it's only gotten worse so he's
probably thrown himself into that I
wouldn't be surprised if he was also
trying to shadow her around and then
there's Katelyn herself who said that
she's not looking for a cure but she
hasn't figured out what she wants to do
with her life so she's still a biologist
she still has access to all of her
mother's lab she still has access to all
the things that mercury labs - which is
where she went during season two like in
the break she had gone to work for them
they convinced her to come back Tina
McGee I don't know what her presence on
the show is going to be but she's not
dead she's still in charge of mercury
labs so Caitlin still has access to all
the same resources but because of her
killer frost nature I wouldn't be
surprised if she breaks bad every once
in a while where you had this in-between
looking version of her this is actually
a picture of her in her trailer
so she still looks very beautiful but
you can see without the CG in like the
full makeup job she just looked kind of
pale in the skin her eyes don't have
that blue glow to them there was one of
you that asked me I forget who it was
but somebody on Twitter asked me if we
would see Caitlin's brother show up
during season three and I actually think
that's a really good idea I don't know
if they'll do it right away but if you
don't remember who that is Caitlin had a
brother who died when he was very young
on earth one but as we know the
multiverse finds ways of surfacing dead
characters the arrow people said the
theme of season six is going to be all
about family I think that's going to be
the same thing on the flash - Caitlin is
still family but there's also a lot of
family of hers that we haven't explored
yet we met her mother during season
three there's a lot of other people that
could pop up we could even meet her
father eventually - and then there's the
idea of a new rogue family so she's one
of those really fun characters that can
do bad stuff with the Rogues because she
is an evil person in the comics but
she's also been good Suicide Squad style
she's on Batman's new version of the
Justice League in the comics right now
she has this crazy hairdo I love her
costume in the comics as much as about
bummers it sounds like they're just
completely messing with the dynamic the
good thing about that is that it opens
the door for something new to come in in
Barry to come back and Riaan spire
everyone so flash rebirth I've already
done a bunch of videos about the
storyline about the idea but it's like
Flash Ragnarok you tear everything down
you destroy it so that you can rebuild
it better than before so if you were
ever hoping
for a new version of the flash costume
season 4 would be it they do change the
costume just a little bit every year we
saw a couple different future versions
of the costume this one's from eight
years in the future and then this one is
from just like a little bit beyond that
because Savitt are didn't become Savitt
are till a little while after that the
only real big suit changes that I'm
expecting are just a little more
highlights like the color might get a
little more cherry red but that's about
it I don't think it's going to
fundamentally change in a huge way it's
not going to start looking like the
armor suit but let me know in the
comments what do you guys think the new
team flash will look like and it to say
nothing of any new characters that they
bring on during the series the lesson I
think they learn from season 3 is not to
bring too many people on at once like
they've already got a couple of new
characters it's to their benefit to just
stick with them develop them and then if
they want to get rid of Julian or they
want to introduce somebody new they can
do it down the road but do it
one character at a time so just bring
everybody on in the first three episodes
the actors are winding down their
vacation Stephen Amell is going crazy on
social media because I guess people are
shaming him for being out of shape
because it's the off season Grant Gustin
has a giant mustache so what you'll
probably see in the next week or so is
pictures of them posting where they're
shaving all that stuff off as they start
shooting that first episode but it'll be
enough time for them to cut a really
quick comic-con trailer because Comic
Con is happening at the end of July but
I'll talk more about what's happening
during that when we get closer so Comic
Con previews will post just like I did
last year but what's going to happen
next is I'm behind on a couple other
videos like American Gods and Doctor Who
and Game of Thrones and stuff like that
so let's say congratulations to Rick
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here to
learn all about episode 1 of the Titans
TV show with Nightwing and all the other
characters and you can click here for
brand new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight